es hat auch ein skandal gegeben rund um
den leichnam von diego maradona kali was
kannst du uns zu diesem foto erzählen
dass wir hier sehen ja leider hat dieser
gute mann der scherzhafte weise sogar
auch diego ist diego molina der name ist
nun mittlerweile bekannt es sich leider
nicht nehmen lassen tatsächlich ein
bestattungsunternehmer ein foto zu
machen er ist mittlerweile auch direkt
gefeuert worden von dem
bestattungsunternehmen der gute mann
wird es jetzt glaube ich in der tat
nicht leicht haben ist ein riesenschritt
formen natürlich schon im internet
entstanden nachdem er das foto gepostet
hat der wird es nicht leicht haben jetzt
weil das ist natürlich anderen
unwürdigkeit nicht zu überbieten da so
ein foto zu machen mit daumen hoch und
sich selber da so wichtig zu nehmen das
macht man einfach nicht
auch auf dem für die familie allein
schon nicht schön zu sehen dass solche
bilder durchs netz gehen mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
beet schau dich hier das nächste video
an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren